whatever i mean broadly thinking because
we tend to think other alien
civilizations would be very human-like
but
if we think of alien civilizations out
there as basically generators of black
holes
however they do it because they get
stars
um do you think there's a lot of them in
our particular universe
out there
in our universe
well okay let me ask okay this is great
let me ask a very generic question
and then
let's see how you answer it which is uh
how many alien civilizations are out
there
if the hypothesis that i just described
is
on the right track yes it would mean
that the parameters of our universe have
been selected so that
intelligent civilizations will occur in
sufficient numbers
so that the if they reach
something like supreme technological
maturity let's define that as the
ability to produce black holes
then that's not a highly improbable
event it
it doesn't need to happen often because
as i just described if one if you get
one of them in a galaxy you're gonna
make more black holes than the stars in
that galaxy
but
there's also not a super strong
motivation well
it's not obvious that you need them to
be ubiquitous throughout the galaxy
right so so one of the things that's
that i try to emphasize in that paper is
that
given this idea of of how
our parameters might have been selected
it's clear that
it's a it's a series of trade-offs right
if you make i mean in order for
intelligent life of our variety or
anything resembling us to occur you need
a bunch of stuff you need stars so
that's right back to smolin's roots of
this idea but you also need
water to have certain certain properties
you need
you need things like the
the
rocky planets like the earth to be
within the habitable zone all these
things that you start talking about in
the
um
the field of astrobiology trying to
understand life in the universe but you
can't over emphasize you can't
tune the parameters so precisely to
maximize the number of stars or to
to give water exactly the properties or
or to make rocky planets like earth the
most numerous you have to compromise on
all these things and so i think the way
to test this idea
is to look at what parameters are
necessary for for each of these
different subsystems and i've laid out a
few that i think are promising there
there could be countless others and see
how
changing the parameters
makes it more or less likely that stars
would form and have long lifetimes or
that or that rocky planets in the
habitable zone are likely to form all
these different things so we can test
how how much these things are in a tug
of war with each other and the
prediction would be that we kind of sit
at this central point where
if you if you move the parameters too
much
stars aren't stable or
life doesn't form or technology's
infeasible because cause life alone at
least the kind of life that we know of
cannot make black holes we don't have
this well i'm speaking for myself
you're a very fit strong person but
it might be possible for you but not for
me to compress matter so we need these
technologies but
we don't know
we have not been able to
quantify yet how
um
finely adjusted the parameters would
need to be in order for silicon to have
the properties it does okay this is not
directly speaking to what you're saying
you're getting to the fermi paradox
which is where are they where are the
the life forms out there how numerous
are they that sort of thing what i'm
trying to argue is that
if this framework is is on the right
track a potentially correct explanation
for our existence
we do it doesn't necessarily predict
that intelligent civilizations are just
everywhere because even if you just get
one of them in a galaxy which is quite
rare
it could be enough to dramatically uh
increase the fecundity of the universe
as a whole yeah and i wonder once you
start generating the offspring for
universes black holes
how
that has effect on the what kind of
effect does it have on the other
uh candidates
civilizations within that universe maybe
it has a destructive aspect or there
could be some arguments about once you
have a lot of offspring that that just
quickly accelerates to where the other
ones can't even catch up it could
but i guess
if you want me to
put my chips on the table or whatever i
think i come down more on the
side that
intelligent
life civilizations are rare
and um
i guess i follow max tegmark here
and also there's there's a lot of papers
coming out recently in the field of
astrobiology that are seeming to say all
right you just work through the numbers
on on some modified drake equation or
something like that and it looks like
it's not improbable you wouldn't you
shouldn't be surprised that an
intelligent species has arisen in our
galaxy but if you think there's one the
next solar system over it's it's highly
improbable so i can see that the number
the probability of finding a
a civilization in a galaxy maybe it's
most likely that you're gonna find
one to a hundred or something but okay
now it's it's really important to put a
time window on that i think because
does that mean in the entire lifetime of
the galaxy before it it um
so for in our case before we run into
andromeda
um
i think it's highly probable i shouldn't
say i think
it's tempting to believe that it's
highly probable that in that entire
lifetime of your galaxy you're going to
get at least one intelligent species
maybe thousands or something like that
but it's also
i think
a little bit naive to think that they're
going to coincide in time and we'll be
able to observe them and also if you
look at the
span of uh
life on earth the earth earth
history
it was surprising to me to kind of look
at
the amount of time well first of all the
the short amount of time there's no life
it's surprising life sprang up pretty
quickly it's cellular single cell but
that was that's the point i'm trying to
make is like so much with what
of life on earth was just like single
cell organisms like most of it most of
it was like boring bacteria type of
stuff well bacteria are fascinating but
i take your point no i get it i mean no
offense to them
this kind of speaking from the
perspective of your paper of something
that's able to generate technology as we
kind of understand it that's a very
short moment in time relative to that
that full history of life on earth and
maybe our universe is just
saturated with
bacteria like
humans right
uh
but
not the special extra
agi
super humans
that those are very rare and once those
spring up
everything just goes to like it it uh
accelerates very quickly
yeah it's it's we just don't have enough
data to really say but i find this whole
subject extremely engaging i mean
there's this concept i think it's called
the rare earth hypothesis which is that
basically stating that okay microbes
were here right away after the haitian
era where we were being bombarded well
after yeah bombarded by comets asteroids
things like that and also after the moon
formed so once things settled down a
little bit
in a few hundred million years you have
microbes everywhere and it could have
been we don't know exactly when it could
have been remarkably brief that that
took so it does indicate that okay life
forms relatively easily i think
that alone is sort of a checker on the
scale for the
argument that
the parameters that allow even microbial
life to form are not just a fluke but
anyway
that aside yes then there was this long
dormant period not dormant things were
happening but
um important things were happening for
some two and a half billion years or
something after
um the metabolic process that releases
oxygen was developed then
basically the plant is just sitting
there getting more and more oxygenated
more and more oxygenated until it's
enough that you can build these large
complex organisms and so the rare earth
hypothesis would argue that
the microbes are common in everywhere in
any planet that's like roughly in the
habitable zone and has some water on
it's probably going to have those but
then getting to this cambrian explosion
that happened some between five and 600
million years ago
that's that's rare you know
and i i buy that i think that is rare so
if you say how much life is in our
galaxy i think that's probably the right
answer is that microbes are everywhere
cambrian explosion is extremely rare
and then
but the cambrian explosion kind of went
like that where
um within a couple tens or 100 million
years
all of these body plans came into
existence and and basically all of the
body plans that are now in existence on
the on the planet
were formed in that brief window
and we've just been
shuffling around since then so then what
what
caused humans to pop out of that i mean
that could be another
extremely rare threshold
that a planet roughly in the habitable
zone with water is not guaranteed to
cross you know to me it's fascinating
for being humble like that humans cannot
possibly be the most amazing thing
that's such if you look at the entirety
of the system that lease mola and you
paint that cannot possibly be the most
amazing thing that process generates so
like if you look at the evolution what's
the equivalent in the cosmological
evolution
and its selection for technology the
equivalent of the human eye or the human
brain universes that are able to do some
like
they don't need the damn stars
they they're able to just do some
incredible generation of complexity fast
on sk like
much more than if you think about it's
like most of our universe is pretty
freaking boring
there's not much going on there's a few
rocks flying around and there's some
like apes that are just like
um
doing podcasts
on some weird planet it just seems very
inefficient if you think about like the
amazing thing the human eye the visual
cortex can do the the the brain the
nervous everything that makes us
more powerful than
single cell organisms like if there's an
equivalent of that for universes
they're like the richness of physics
that could be uh
they could be expressed through a
particular set of parameters
like
i mean
that
like for me i'm uh so from a computer
science perspective a huge fan of
cellular automata which is a nice
sort of pretty visual way to illustrate
how different laws can result in uh
drastically different levels of
complexity so like
it's like yeah okay so we're all like
celebrating look our little cellular
automata is able to generate pretty
triangles and squares and therefore we
achieve general intelligence and then
there'll be like
some badass chuck norris type like
uh
universal touring machine type of
cellular automata they're able to
generate other cellular automata
that does any arbitrary level of
computation off the bat
it like those have to then exist
and then we're just like this we're just
we'll be forgotten is this the story
this is uh
this podcast just entertains a few other
apes for
for a few months well i i'm kind of
surprised to hear your cynicism
no i'm very i i usually think of you as
like a one who celebrates humanity in
all its forms and things like that and i
i guess i just i don't i see it the way
you just described i mean okay fif we've
been here for 13.7 billion years and
you're saying
gosh that's a long time let's get on
with the show already some other
universe could have kicked our butt by
now but
that's putting a characteristic i mean
why is 13.7 billion a long time i mean
compared to compared to what i guess so
when i look at our universe i see this
extraordinary hierarchy that has
developed over that time so at the
beginning it was a chaotic mess of
you know some
plasma and
nothing interesting going on there and
it even for the first stars to form that
a lot of
really interesting uh evolutionary
processes had to occur
by evolutionary in that sense i just
mean
um taking place over extended periods of
time
and structures are forming then and then
it took that first generation of stars
in order to
produce the metals
that then can more efficiently produce
another generation of stars we're only
the the third generation of stars so we
might still be pretty quick to the to
the game here so
i but i don't think i don't okay so then
so then you have these stars now you
have solar systems on those solar
systems you have
um
rocky worlds you have gas giants like
all this complexity and then you start
getting life and the
the complexity that's evolved through
the evolutionary process in life forms
is just
it's not a letdown to me just no no and
there's some of it is like some some of
the planets is like icy it's like
different flavors of ice cream they're
icy but there might be water under yeah
all kinds of life forms with some
volcanoes right all kinds of weird stuff
no no i i don't uh i think it's
beautiful i think our life is beautiful
and i think it was uh designed that by
by design the scarcity of the whole
thing i think mortality as terrifying as
it is is fundamental to the whole
reason we enjoy everything no i think
it's beautiful i just think that all of
us
um conscious beings in the grand scheme
of basically every at every scale will
be completely forgotten well that's true
i think everything is transient and that
would go back to maybe something more
like
lao tzu the dao de jing or something
where it's like
yes
there is nothing but change there is
nothing but emergence and dissolve and
that that's it but i just
in this picture of this hierarchy that's
developed i don't mean to say that now
it gets to us and that's the pinnacle in
fact i think
at a high level the story i'm trying to
tease out in my research is about okay
well so then what's the next level of
hierarchy and if in if it's
okay we're we're kind of pretty smart i
mean talking about people like lee small
and allen goose max tegmark okay we're
really smart talking about me okay we're
kinda
we can find our way to the grocery store
or whatever but sometimes but what's
next you know i mean what if what if
there's another level of hierarchy that
grows on top of us that is even more
profoundly capable and
i mean we've talked a lot about
superconducting sensors imagine these
uh cognitive systems far more capable
than us residing
somewhere else in the solar system off
of the surface of the earth where it's
much darker much colder much more
naturally suited to them and they have
these sensors that can detect
single photons of light uh from radio
waves out to all across the spectrum to
gamma rays and just see the whole
universe and they just live in space
with these massive
um
collection optics so that they what what
do they do they just look out and and
experience that
that vast array of
of what's
being developed
and if you're such a system
presumably you would do some things for
fun
and it the kind of fun thing i would do
somebody who likes video games is i
would create and maintain and observe
something like earth
and
uh so in some sense we're like all what
players on on a stage for this uh
super conducting um
cold
computing system out there i mean all of
this is fascinating to think the the
fact that you're actually designing
systems here on earth that are trying to
push this technological at the very
cutting edge and also thinking about how
does the
like the evolution of physical laws
lead us to
the way we are
it's fascinating that that coupling is
fascinating it's like the ultimate
rigorous application of philosophy
to the rigorous application of
engineering
so i um jeff you're one of the most
fascinating i'm i'm so glad i did not
know much about you except through your
work and i'm so glad we got this um
chance to talk your
your
one of the best explainers of
exceptionally difficult concepts um
and you're also the
speaking of like fractal you're able to
function intellectually at all levels of
the stack which which i deeply
appreciate this was really fun you're a
great educator great scientist it's
it's an honor that you spend your
valuable time with me it's an honor that
you would spend your time with me as
well thanks jeff
you